mine's about a reporter in North  Carolina he's going viral for his  unexpectedly funny weather segment look  at this Justin Hinton is his name he was  covering a snow storm last week when he  says that he accidentally turned on the  face filter the [ __ ] on Facebook live  not realizing the effect was turned on  he continued support while he shuffled  through some very funny faces there's  one with some googly eyes is very good  Kenton said he's happy that he was able  to give people a laugh and smile this I  like that too yeah but there's one with  some googly eyes he had no idea that  this was happening there's a sir one I  think is aware he had no idea that this  was happening  there's a sir one I think is hilarious  no I know is that local news is often  that it's called a one-man show one  person out there with your own your own  lighting effect you know it's very  defined that you do kind of miss the  forecast oh what's the weather was a  rarity in this area